we're asked to divide and simplify and
we have one radical expression over
another radical expression the key to
simplify this is to realize if I have
the square the principal root of x over
the principal root of y this is the same
thing as the principal root of x over Y
and it really just comes out of the
exponent properties if I have two things
but I take to some power and picking the
principal root is the same thing as
taking it to the one-half power if I'm
raising each of them to some power and
then dividing that's the same thing as
dividing first and then raising them to
that power so let's apply that over here
this expression over here is going to be
the same thing as the principal root the
principal it's hard to write a radical
sign that big the principal root of 60 x
squared Y over 48 X and then we can
first look at the coefficient terms or
the coefficients of each of these
expressions and try to simplify that
both the numerator and the denominator
is divisible by 12 60 divided by 12 is 5
48 divided by 12 is 4 both the numerator
and the denominator is divisible by X x
squared divided by X is just X X divided
by X is 1 anything we divide the
numerator by we have to divide the
denominator by and that's all we have
left so if we wanted to simplify this
this becomes this is equal to the the
make a radical sign and then we have 5/4
5/4 5/4 and actually we can write it a
little slightly different way but I'll
write it this way 5/4 and we have
nothing left in the denominator other
than that 4 and in the numerator we have
an X and we have a Y we have an X and we
have a Y and now we could leave it just
like that but we might want to take more
things out of the radical sign and so
one possibility that you can do is you
could say that this is really the same
thing as this is equal to 1/4 times 5 5
X Y all of that under the radical sign
and this is the same thing as the square
root of or the principal root of 1/4
times the principal root of 5x y and the
square root of 1/4 if you think about it
that's just 1/2 times 1/2 or another way
you could think about it is this is the
same thing this right here is the same
thing as so you could just say hey this
is 1/2 1/2 times 1/2 is 1/4 or if you
don't realize it's 1/2 you say hey this
is the same thing as the square root of
1 over the square root of 4 and the
square root of 1 is 1 and square root
the principal root of 4 is 2 so you get
1/2 once again and so if you simplify
this right here to 1/2 then the whole
thing can simplify to 1/2 times the
principal root I'll just write it all in
orange times the principal root of 5 X Y
and there's nothing else that you can
really take out of the radical sign here
nothing else here is a perfect square